welcome to death kitchen how are you
feeling
how are you it's very good fine thank
you what's the secret about tonight's
service what are you going to do
differently we're going to do everything
perfectly gorgeous everything perfectly
yes chef got to hear it actor how are
you i'm very excited um just want to
serve my customers yeah
now i need one of you
can walk out here this evening as a
winner yes yeah you're here because
you're the best you gotta prove it now
curry corner from cheltenham and la san
from birmingham are our top two indian
contenders here's how i found them
we're a nation of curry fans it's one of
britain's favorite dishes i knew the f
word viewers nominated hundreds of
indian restaurants
but we could only choose two to compete
in the f-word kitchen
the search took us all over britain
determined to find the very best we went
to visit your culinary heroes
from nottingham to portsmouth london to
tamworth southampton to leeds all of
these things got very definite flavors
it's absolutely delicious
we tasted food fit for the maharaja
but sometimes the surroundings weren't
quite so impressive i hope the food's
good
that's the deck i was shocking i feel
like i'm in pete dobson's bathroom
this is proper authentic indian food
served inside a cafe with cafe prices
the food is delicious it looks like this
money has been has been here has been
sitting here for ages it's absolutely
disgusting
[Music]
after months of whittling down the
nominations we finally found two
outstanding restaurants
[Music]
kerry corner and cheltenham gave us a
fantastically warm welcome
nestling in the heart of the cotswolds
this is one of the oldest bangladeshi
restaurants in britain how are you
good to see you how are you very indeed
thank you what lovely place head chef
samshall crowery is still going strong
at 59
helped in the kitchen by his wife salaha
and daughter marusha
my god look at the size of the kitchen
it's small it's my news so you're not
the head chef are you i think if i
claimed to be the head chef my head
would be off so i won't even bother good
very nice that's why you see everything
nice
which
can you just leave us alone for two
minutes please have a quick chat with
your mom thank you
talk about a proper family run friendly
business incredible in the kitchen with
your wife your daughter and your son in
front of house
he's been cooking for 42 years
before i was [ __ ] born
every single person in this family loves
food cooks it eats it thinks about it
every single moment
first up for me samosas extraordinary
foods you have to travel to bangladesh
to get that kind of flavor
and he's managed it longshan where do
you go the lamb shank just slides down
the bar and i mean it's cooked perfectly
i haven't even tasted it yet but you can
just tell
[Music]
it would be an absolute dream come true
to win the airport's best local
restaurant it would mean the world to us
i'm happy we're going to win
thank you for that um
my problem is that this is a
tough category
because there are amazing indian
restaurants across the country
sadly
the bad news is there's only two
restaurants that can go through to the
f-word restaurants
congratulations you're one of them oh my
god
next time is gonna be the f-word ration
for 50 diners and trust me
they're tough cookies congratulations
i'll see you in london
definitely the right decision without a
shadow of doubt this place is unique
it's refined they've managed to focus on
flavour gordon's expecting great things
from us so we just hope we can deliver
oh yes
you don't know why okay
[Music]
so curry corner from cheltenham is
through and in a group with such high
standards we found a brilliant and
worthy opponent la san in birmingham
good to see you good to see you
stunningly stylish lausanne is a city
center favorite
head chef akhtar islam was just 22 years
old when he opened the restaurant with
his best friend jabba
the young guns from the midlands are
determined to be different with
cutting-edge cuisine for birmingham we
were the pioneers we were the first
restaurant to break away from the
mainstream and offer alternatives to
your baltis and your tikka masalas
that's exquisitely presented finesse
very competitive you know we're set out
to be number one and hopefully one day
we'll make it
home
chicken thank you
with fried ginger
what's the ambition the sand what is it
it's not food for
people who haven't got an educated
palette it is a very sophisticated
cuisine i haven't come across any indian
food anyway yet with fried leeks sun
dried tomatoes fried ginger that's dried
in the oven i mean it's just everything
that goes into the actual food itself
yeah
that is as authentic we're just
ultimately we're trying to bring the
food forward a bit so you're looking for
a michigan style
i'm hoping to get mission star yeah
that's the plan i love his arrogance
because he reminds me
very similar to myself you know 15 years
ago the biggest problem that you have
today is that you're trying too hard the
arrogance versus the confidence you've
got a little bit of me in there
and you know there's only two
restaurants you can go through and cook
in the f-word
[Music]
and you're one of them congratulations
chef welcome thank you very much just i
do want to kiss you
we've done it
i mean it's amazing it is probably the
the biggest thing that
has ever happened to any of us i
definitely think i've made the right
decision
one hell of a cocky chef young but
bloody talented
[Music]
so i found my top two indian restaurants
well the f-word diners prefer curry
corners traditional charm
or lasan's ambitious modern take on
indian food who'll be crowned the f
word's best local indian restaurant
we're about to find out
now both teams are going to cook 25
portions of the starters and make sure
those customers pay for your food
excited
yeah chef yeah okay let's go andrew
stations let's get ready for starters
yeah let's go
we're back in london at the f word
restaurant
and tonight is indian night
the value of the indian food market in
britain is around 500 million pounds
but who does it best
we searched the country and found the f
word's top two local indian restaurants
la san in birmingham and curry corner in
cheltenham
okay guys first couple of tables coming
in right listen listen up please don't
order full covers table one four lamb
samosas yes chef yes you don't have to
shout for theirs but thank you anyway
right curry corner listen up please
focus four yes four lamb samosas yeah
sure yes chef tonight both brigades are
kicking off with samosas here's my
recipe for this delicious indian starter
[Music]
chickpea samosas delicious simple and so
straightforward first the filling
vegetable oil not too hot don't want to
burn those spices curry powder garam
masala
cumin
turmeric
[Music]
fry
onion
in the spices seasoned
cream chilli
just wakes everything up
garlic
ginger
next add chickpeas and peas
water
nice
simmer
lemon juice lightly crush
cool
samosa dough roll
cut out
take the disc and just cut it in half
form a little cone
fill
water
[Music]
seal nip together
nice and gently
[Music]
hot pan
vegetable oil
fry
salad
out
chickpea mosses with salad and raita
dressing
done
guys this is not a race okay it's a
restaurant actor yes yes give me time on
the first four please essan
how long two minutes
good man excellent both freshman's are
cooking their own samosa recipes it'll
be interesting to see who comes out on
top
la san in birmingham pride themselves on
taking authentic indian cooking in an
exciting and modern direction
it's an old boys club
and we are
the new generation
for their lamb samosa they marinate the
meat in raw papaya paste for 24 hours to
make sure it's exquisitely tender
and they're using a special kind of thin
biscuity pastry called nimki
adding nigella seeds for an aromatic
flavor
the filling inside the samosa is lamb
and that's spiced with the usual you
know you've got chili turmeric raised it
is braised but then what we do we
totally evaporate all the sauce then we
just pound it mix it with some mint and
coriander and it's just uh put into the
pastry very easy i think you'll enjoy
the food yeah i hope the diners like it
as well those first four hectares that
sounds like
now you're using a cutter for yours yeah
yes okay i want to see you behind that
the secret behind it is it'll just seal
the pastry off yeah and also this is how
it's made at home
[Music]
family run curry corner in cheltenham
have been serving their traditional home
style indian food for 32 years
we've got probably 100 years worth of
cooking experience between all of us our
family is all about food and i don't
think you can beat that
for their samosa filling curry corner
cooked the lamb with roast spices
cinnamon cardamon bay leaves and cloves
for their dough they're using a light
whole wheat flour that can be rolled out
into a much thinner pastry
this recipe is actually my grandmother's
recipe and so it's a lot more
home style
as opposed to
any any of my cooking i mean samosa any
of my cookies yes my home cooking i
always follow my mom's step yeah they
look fantastic away now five more please
yes
well done
so you're quite a modern young cook
thank you very much i know you when
lagerlast turned up to the restaurant
expecting a chicken tikka masala and a
beer it does it does annoy me it's not
something that you know an experience i
have to enjoy very often indian food can
offer so much more so why take up many
space with the tiki masala right simple
ass in my kitchen i'll never serve that
you'll never serve a chicken chicken
masala never serve chicken chicken salad
if you try my masala challenge and
nobody makes in uk masala do you have
the best i am any chef
you challenge actor any any chef yes any
chef how long we've been cooking
champshow
41 years 41 years how old are you hector
i'm twin nine chef when was the last
time you ate a chicken chicken masala um
when i was putting out two last year
about 12 years ago how was it uh
horrible so uh i didn't like the amount
of food coloring in there i thought it
was totally unnatural in color do you
want the shampoo to email the recipe for
you uh more than welcome but it wouldn't
find its way into my menu i mean
i don't use any color in my restaurant
what
like a lovely orangey color from all the
caramelization of the browning of the
onions and all the rest of the masala
you freshly grind the spices down in
release flavors and it'll color up the
curry naturally all right but um if you
said it was red then i'd i'd probably
say
that that's fine that's well done but
what i would say i mean when you
mentioned the tikka masala
they don't even have that practice of
cooking in bangladesh did i use the
tandoor apartment
oh jesus
you don't know nothing about bangladesh
let's agree to disagree an actor is an
indian snob yes
okay yeah i need two totals of four from
you yeah yeah and we'll go in the box
okay
oh my gosh
now everybody loves a curry but as actor
would tell us there's so much more to
indian cookery than a chicken tikka
masala
over 6 000 indian restaurants in the uk
serve 3 million happy customers a week
but the vast majority of dishes they
offer are either chicken or lamb
thank you
it's all delicious but i believe with
such a limited range of meats we're
missing out on a world of cunnery
opportunity
and to prove this i'm going to recreate
a true indian classic using a piece of
meat that you won't find on your average
indian menu anywhere
venison
[Music]
it's a wonderfully rich gamey ingredient
that's a perfect match for highly spiced
flavors
i've come to scotland in search of the
finest wild deer for my delicious new
dish
one that deserves a place on any indian
menu venison masala
i'm hunting with mobarak jan who
regularly stalks deer up here
most indian restaurants use halal meat
and i'm keen to know how wild venison
can be halal
mo's a muslim hunter and he's going to
show me how he does it what was it
attracted to why why do you want to
start shooting well it's mainly really
sort of um
the
sort of hunter-gatherer kind of thing
you know shooting for your own food
taking it home taking some venison home
and cooking it up and having beautiful
food
joining us is jim mccurlin who's going
to help us track down a deer if you spot
one and i haven't seen it
just go
and that's all
i'll hear it yeah don't point out it
don't point don't raise any hands
are we ready let's go i was born ready
but deer are elusive creatures and
incredibly difficult to shoot and what
could spook him noise
scent
after two hours jim spots our first deer
see those tall trees up there yes he's
just out he's just come out
here he comes
he's running along the bottom
[ __ ] i still can't see
him top left see him
oh yeah
yeah
just as i'm getting ready to take the
shot
[Music]
i lose it
gordon that deer
[Music]
next day we set off again but the deer
always seemed to be one step ahead of us
finally after several hours of hard slog
jim spotted a roe deer
hello
safety off
no
yeah
[Applause]
i follow up with the second shot
he's dead
yeah quite strange feeling to being with
isn't it yes
but when you've got it in your sights
like that your heart's just beating
absolutely
big deep breath they call it buck fever
then it's time for mo to show me how he
makes sure he's dear is halal
as well as saying the prayer when he
pulls the trigger he slits the throat in
a special way what i would do yeah to
make it hello yeah you used to repeat
the prayer bismuth
that's it that's it one swift back and
forth that's the main thing with halal
the knife has to be razor sharp we do it
this way to get all the blood out the
carcass
um just so it's nice and clean
well done gordon
it's the moment of truth time for me to
cook my venison masala for mo and jim
i'm gonna be using venison that most
shot of the weekend it's been hung and
chilled and more importantly he shot it
so therefore is halal the first thing
i'm going to do is make the most amazing
dry rub
mix cumin fennel seeds chili powder
coriander seeds and chili flakes
trying that down
nice
rub the spices into the meat
into the pan
nice
cook for about four minutes basting
continuously
then remove from the heat and as it
starts to cool down in the oil it takes
on
all that wonderful flavor from the
spices
for the masala sauce grate one onion
season and add garam masala turmeric
garlic and ginger
we can afford to make it a little bit
more spicy because it's going up against
the dense rich venison
add chilies chopped tomatoes and a
splash of water
grater whole cauliflower and add to the
mix masala paste starts to absorb it
finally add chopped coriander and a
squeeze of lemon
and there you go that's not worth six
hours pissing around in the bushes i
don't know what it is
but i'm really keen to find out if moe
likes my venison masala
you like that that's gonna stop that's
what i want to see that smile on your
face that's good stuff what do you think
of venison everyone thinks it's
associated with posh dinners but i've
always thought it goes quite well with
the indian spices
quite dense quite gamey yeah why don't
they use it across indian cuisine to be
honest i don't think it's available it's
readily available there's another like
lamb and chicken and stuff there's a new
business for you yeah hello edison
last table of four champs sure yes sir
last table actor you've got one table
two
last two yeah goes out like exact same
as the first two yeah
huh
yes last table good all right well done
sure yes well done
i really enjoyed the starter all the
flavours worked together meat was really
really tender and the coating was really
nice and crispy it wasn't too spicy just
a nice balanced dish really flavoursome
actually i was really really impressed
now how do you think he's doing tonight
he's doing very well yeah as expected i
just think he's not in there helping
anymore no no i'll leave him to live him
to it you had the curry corn samosa
that's right um i'm not impressed i'm
fred the approach was good it was
authentic and it's how it was intended
with the pastry to too heavy too thick
and the filling unfortunately wasn't
flavoursome or
[Applause]
elect salt and other other spices i got
to get the kicking from you oh my god
more importantly you're going to pay for
it no no
enjoy your main courses thank you thank
you
the style was great actually it was
really soft and succulent inside the
spices all complemented each other
really well the lamb was just cooked
really well crispy pastry it was to die
for really really good
now nice to see you how are you welcome
to deathwork
beautiful thank you now how do you think
samso's doing how do you think he's
pairing up on the pressure it's very
well he's doing very good are you a
proud wife
of course of course i'm a proud do you
want to jump in there again and give him
a hand
no no no he's all right you can cook it
uh now what do you think of lasagna's um
the feeling uh is okay but the pastry is
too thin for me and i feel it too oily
for me and the most important question
are you gonna be paying for it tonight
no no no wow well how was it yeah it was
the semester itself was to be honest yes
right the lamb was very nice very well
cooked go on yes or no are you paying
for it yeah you're gonna pay for it good
to see you excellent
so curry corner first
nice and crispy
pastry's fantastic
the samosa filling
i'd want to be a little bit more spicy
it's a shame because you start cutting
through the pastry and it's like wow
crispy
delicious blistered all over and then
you get to the
center and it's not as exciting as the
outside now actors inside peas braised
lamb
wow that's delicious it doesn't actually
look like a classic samosa however the
flavor is extraordinary
right time to get the scores yes how
well do you think you did out of
championship how many customers yeah
i've done very good actor how old you
think you did 25 out of 25 25 i love
your confidence okay right jb let's go
here we go okay curry corner first
the number of customers yeah out of 25
that are happy to pay
for your samosa
is
wow
18 out of 25 well done
really well done
really good 18.
really good um feedback please what was
too oily the pastry oily yeah
okay right less hands the number
of customers out of 25 are willing to
pay for your samosas is
24 out of 25 well done
well done
really well
really good news
really good news
now here we go 18 out of 25 yes and 24
out of 25 yeah two very good results
good clear down get ready for main
course let's go well done
now both wrestlers will put their main
courses to their diners first up la san
hey gentlemen we've got pan-fried fillet
bass with the bengali fish broth please
lasan's fillet of sea bass in bengali
fish broth is a modern indian dish
derived from a traditional recipe
first aktar heats mustard oil adds
mustard seeds just a generous pinch and
we're going to wait
for that to start popping
curry leaves onions and garlic and
allows to sweat
he then adds two whole chilis snapping
them at the ends the seeds stay inside
but we're trying to get the flavor
because we don't want it to make it too
hot
aktar adds turmeric coriander and chili
powder a little bit more than the
coriander three times as much as the
turmeric next fish heads full of intense
flavor
akhtar is using roy bengali carp which
adds to the authenticity of this dish
then he adds tomatoes coriander water
and simmers
after an hour the broth is strained
he cooks potatoes in the broth and adds
lime juice
the sea bass fillets are seasoned with
turmeric chili then coated in rice flour
it's going to help us get skin very
crispy
they're fried skin side down
and turned
[Music]
pan fried fillets of sea bass in bengali
fish broth
served
right what's the secret behind that
broth the major flavors are coming
through on that is the coriander garlic
and um tomato with a hint of chili or a
bit of a kick looks very nice
lovely
i know if you don't get 15 out of 50
paying for your main course you're going
to be gutting tonight come on i'm going
to cry
you can't let this boy beat you come on
this is what curry corner have on
tonight's menu
curry corner's signature dish is
monkfish and saffron cream curry
first shampoo fry some fresh garlic and
ginger he then adds salt cardamom pods
cloves bay leaves
and stirs in a whole crushed cinnamon
stick
shampoo adds onions and red peppers with
tomato puree
cumin turmeric coriander and chili
powder measuring by eye with his 40
years of experience
then he lets the flavors really infuse
large fish
chamsell then coats the monkfish with
pepper
mustard seeds fennel seeds and aguan an
asian spice that tastes a lot like thyme
he then fries the fish
to finish the sauce sham saul heats a
spoonful of his spice mix in a pan and
adds cream
then milk with saffron and lime leaves
a chopped spring onion
vine tomato and fresh coriander
finally he adds his monk fish coconut
milk and shredded coconut
complete
hmong fish and saffron cream curry
served
what makes that dish stand out they're
very very subtle flavoring from the
spices but it's a very delicate flavor
octal's broth has a strong pungent kick
to it yours is very delicate it's very
delicate because the fish is very
delicate right and all we need is
something to just lift the sweetness of
the fish which is the most important
part
each dish is looking like the first
let's go hold on
service please let's go
right now it's time to check on janet
street farmer
this year i'm challenging janet street
porter to raise all the meat for the
competition final at the f word
restaurant
last week she started a farm with seven
miniature dexter cattle
look i'm in charge now
this week i'm adding to janet's
challenge with the rarest breed of pork
we've ever had in the f-word kitchen
the bully mangalitza
to help her choose three piglets i've
sent her to meet an old friend pig
expert christine ko i've forgotten my
wellies so i hope that i'm gonna be very
wet
is that a pig that is a pig looks like
she's wearing a wig
sure this pig hasn't got a two pair no
look give her a stroke do i have to she
got fleas no that's right mangalitsas
were first bred in hungary in the early
19th century
closely related to wild boar and with a
nervous temperament to match mangalitzas
produce beautiful meat with a stronger
gamier flavour and as the fattiest pig
in the world they're perfect for salami
cured loin and bacon yeah oh it's so
wary isn't it wonderful oh my god it's
like pubic hair well not like any pubic
hair i've seen anyway enough about the
sow it's time for janet to meet her
piglets this has taken just over a
couple of weeks ago
oh yeah it looks like it's right doesn't
it yeah
they're so tiny when they're born
absolutely but they're straight right
into the teeth so they're highly
intelligent they are they they they
always sift them on the bottom so that's
how they recognize them oh no
well i know they're going to be tasty
because i've just eaten a sausage made
from one of their ancestors
six weeks have passed so they're ready
to go to their new mum
and janet's three now not so little pigs
are arriving in yorkshire oh sorry
before they can go into the brand new
pen janet needs to give him a quick
health check can i wear these yeah i'm
not going to wear them because i need to
be able to finish you're at one with
pigs i'm on a learning curve
i'll calm down
now we have to try and stay very relaxed
around them
right look at its eyes nice clear eyes
they're not runny they're not runny nose
not runny not very runny no you're fine
trotters try to look perfect what stinky
little trotters you've got can you just
have a look at the bottom to see if he's
got the runs
ugh how do i know just look and poke
about a bit i'm not ugh nothing i'm not
waiting for him to have the runs and
what sex is it
what we got underneath well there's a
lump what does that mean have we got a
knee at the back i can't tell christine
i don't know what i'm looking for it's a
boy how do you know it's a boy
because it's got really probably not a
lump that'll do i'll stand still for
god's sake 11 kilos right meet you mate
so that they're ready for the f word
restaurant i need each pig to gain from
one and a half to two kilos in weight
each week the equivalent of two bags of
sugar
this one's much heavier but you're
leaning on it
it's really important to do these checks
particularly after they've had a little
bit of stress and a long journey just to
make sure they're starting off healthy
you are now the proud owner of three of
the rarest pigs in the uk
they look fantastic look make the
neighbours
janet's chosen her pigs and cows and all
she needs now to complete her mixed
grill is some chickens her challenge is
about to get even harder
fancy meeting you here
i'm really good to see you now kyle's
last week pigs this week yeah how are
they they're fantastic they're so lively
really but i picked a special breed of
pig manga elixir pit do you like them
yeah i like their hair oh really
blonde right pubic more sort of the
green two thousand gray
it's like your hair but i think curly
i'll ride okay i think that's why you
picked this next so you're saying i've
got cubes on top of my head you had
trouble finding their penises as well
that is the kind of thing you're
obsessed with no i'm not no but i've
never taken a problem journey through
life i've never
every time i comb their hair yes i'll be
thinking of you
yeah come on guys you're the best
freshman to prove it yes yes tomorrow
night none of you're gonna get another
chance to do this again so really make
it count
the seafast was pan-fried to perfection
it was really lovely in the broth it was
absolutely perfect the sea bass was
quite lively i think it was quite a
modern take on indian cuisine everything
together just complimented each other it
was beautiful and i would definitely pay
for
sea bass i like very much but this is
the dish i i find this too hot for me
oh the monk fish is amazing the flavors
really worked and and it wasn't too rich
it was really beautiful the monkfish it
was quite tough and i just think that
the spices there was no kick to it no
kick to the dish
right
so less and sea bass looks amazing in
terms of presentation
yeah it's bold but it's incredibly
delicious that broth is very very rich
and that wakes up the sea bass very good
curry corners monkfish
looks more traditional
it's very delicate
and i like it but it's not spicy enough
that needs to be
a little bit more aggressive in terms of
flavor the sea bass for me the broth
seals it
right let's find out how you did
out of 50. take an educated guess
which we see
no i don't know
35 35 50. actor 50. how well do you
think that's the best went down
i'm hoping we'll we'll be in the high
40s fingers crossed okay
let's do you first yeah
the number of customers that are happy
to pay for your sea bass out of 50 is
40 out of 50. well done
really well done
[Applause]
really really well that's good
really well done
40 out of 50. that's good
so jb uh 10 customers didn't pay for
this fast why yeah too spicy about 40
out of 50. that's bloody good right
curry corner the number of customers
willing to pay for your lung fish out of
50
is
27 out of 50.
27.
damn
that's tough that's 23 customers out of
50. not happy to pay no why not
to blend and the fish to rubbery as one
and the fish being too rubbery yeah okay
don't be disappointed
you can pull this back
on dessert
yes you've got to get 25 out of 25 a
dessert
yes you're both talented enough to do it
yeah clear down let's go yeah well done
you never know they might be able to
turn it around still optimistic that
they will they will win
now is one of britain's most loved
comedians is he's cooking as good as his
jokes i'm about to find out are you
ready yes very excited very happy to be
here i'm going to cook some jamaican
food
i need dumpling i need pumpkin i need
yam yes chef nah what are you cooking
i'm cooking pepper pot soup my mom used
to cook it and it's just something that
jamaicans have she used to serve it in a
terrine
for each member of the family
it's why our family is so big we just go
come on now the food ready
get a spoon
what are you making over there i'm gonna
do my childhood favorite soup scotch
broth oh scotch broth using mutton and
barley
barley yeah i don't know if you've got
food like this but it's one of those
things where you miss it and so you know
my mom passed away in 1998. so when i
eat it anywhere like there's a place in
london called um savannah jerk yep which
is a very good jamaican restaurant that
i love going to yeah and they they gave
it to me the other day and uh i sort of
burst into tears really yeah because
that's memorable well it's one of those
evocative meals you know that you kind
of think okay of course so how did dawn
and your mum get on really well done
bondage straight away oh yeah first time
john came to my house right my mom used
to do this it was like a cooking test
with every new girlfriend you know my
mum used to bring this plate of food out
like this that was like eight feet high
and it was chicken and rice and dumpling
and green banana and yam and sweet
potatoes and literally dawn's head was
like that over the top like that
yourself darling
and so um and what you've got to do is
you've got to you've got to show that
you've got some heart and eat it you
know and she did eat it i was very proud
of her clearly she passed the test yeah
she passed a test how is your namby
pamby scottish broth with barley going
partly cooking the mutton in a light
stock for 20 minutes so it gets really
nice and tender the important part bring
up the ball and skim the top vegetables
celery carrots swede turnips and then
barley okay what i've done is i've put
the meat and the kidney beans in to
boil it says boil typical jamaican while
the meat on the arm the beans for 20
minutes non-stop
until then done and then put in the
vegetables and let them simmer so i'm
doing the meat bit first
you've had some fantastic reviews from
fellow there's a fellow a carrot that
you can relate to i can relate to him a
lot actually because he's the only black
guy in the village
one of the first calls i went to i was
one of three black kids in the entire
school if anything got stolen they'd
just go blackhead
blackhead one get over here did you do
this as you know dawn was a guest the f
word which i had the most amazing snook
[Music]
you had a snog with my wife with was
just uh you know
you don't mind do you yes i do find put
your willy on this block and let's make
toast she left something is she can you
give it two are you saying that please
are there any times that's a good joke
it's not like
are there any times across the show live
that you forget your lines it's a live
performance you know there are going to
be times when your concentration might
slip for a brief second did you ever get
tempted to throw in a little joke like a
okay something
i'll tell you okay
nuts i grew up in strap
katango my friends you can't do that i
was very tempted the other night i
started saying something three times the
tyrant
the tyrant
the tyrant
and i was so attempted to go shaka khan
retired
so the mutton's been cooking now for 25
minutes it's now nice and soft all that
fat has been removed adding that into
the vegetables and then topping that up
with the stock barley's in so it's just
started to open up
and this is the stock that the mutton's
been cooked in
bring it up to the boil create the
seasoning turn it down and let it simmer
i'm trying to make the dumplings now
i've also got scotch bonnet pepper in my
eyes
i'm about to take one of my contact
lenses out because i'm clearly dying
right now both suits have to cook for 20
minutes then the blind tasters will pick
a winner and i can already smell victory
something burning over there god damn
i think i put too much scotch money in
there right welcome back to the f-word
now
time for the results of the recipe
challenge first we've got to plate up
ready
yours smells delicious we're good right
jb yes off you go good luck thank you jb
you're doing an audition for a boy band
or something
spicy
it's quite thick though it is
the lamb can be a bit more tender
it's just a bit spicy
that is really nice
this looks nice mmm fresh herbs deeper
flavor i just had a peppercorn
gives a lovely texture
all right good luck good luck good luck
oh no he's got that look about him
okay let's go how did they go down first
in yours they loved the fight it was
very like homie style mm-hmm
very nice uh yeah yeah he stole it from
his mother yeah right
the score is 41.
four to one
the winner is
yeah
it went down yeah gordon i liked yours
it was nice thank you perfect winter too
i got cake i lost pauline i beat him
well well of course you beat
out of my kitchen
yes
huh how competitive is he that's bad
isn't it look how happy he is come on
right now it's time for dessert
it's fantastic to spice up desserts this
is a delicious saffron poached pear with
a cardamom custard
first peel your pears
half
core add 150 grams of caster sugar to
boiling water
then a pinch of saffron
poach the pears for 20 minutes
mint and cardamom custard add 300
milliliters of milk to a saucepan
four crushed cardamom pods
slowly bring to the boil
sieve
three egg yolks
50 grams of sugar
add the cardamom fused milk
and return to the heat
stir constantly and allow to thicken
[Music]
mint
drain the pears
cast the sugar
glaze
that smells delicious
saffron poached pear with mint and
cardamom custard
done
once you've added the sugar into this
you've got the whisker okay if you leave
it okay
it goes grainy there you go whisk whisk
whisk they're good
don't slice them too thin otherwise i'll
break yeah
good that's it uh
yeah sure yes i thought your dear lady
earlier your wife she's very proud of
you tonight you know that
i'm mauricio too but she doesn't think
actors are meant for you by the way
there'll be a lot of mothers who think
that
good good service please
very nice very nice that customer looks
fantastic okay well done good
it must be hard for you walking around
cheltenham they ask you for autographs
think of your george clooney
do they yeah no all the time
see easy
okay how are we doing that's it okay yes
[ __ ] good are you ready to go
good lovely good
excellent
i thought it was marvelous i love the
contrast of
savory and sweet it was absolutely
beautiful the crispy mint was just
perfect it just blended everything
together perfectly thoroughly enjoyable
really enjoyed it i finished it all very
light very nice
it was light it was fragrant
and generally i really enjoyed it and i
might have finished my sisters
okay first off end of the night well
done i think all four of you done
brilliantly well and you are a true
legend yes thank you well done really
well done
okay ready for the results jb please
okay
thank you curry corner let's start with
you first yes the number of customers
that are happy to pay out of 25 for
their dessert is
19 out of 25. well done really fantastic
huh that's great news
that means
in total you have got
64 out of 100.
really good indeed
okay
this is a big moment
the number of edward diners yes that are
happy to pay out of 25 yeah for your
poached pears is
12 out of 25
but there is good news because you have
a total of 76 out of 100.
congratulations for you
now all of you do me a big favor and get
out of here and get yourself a lassie
well done
really well done
the excellent is absolutely amazing i
mean you know we've made it so far and
to have one as well i mean i'm just
shaking inside on it it's just
so la san are in first place on the
f-word leaderboard but can they hold on
to the top spot and go through to the
next round